We got a really funny voice mail.
Sam Ceder, host of The Majority Report, and
I were in what as far as I knew, was like
a fake feud over YouTube subscribers.
But really, it's all about just growing independent
media.
Here's a caller who thought the feud was real
and doesn't like it and also came up with
a really funny metaphor.
Let's listen to it.
Yeah, I just wanted to leave a message and
let you know something I heard you say the
other day or a couple weeks ago on your show
that are you were you were giving your ragging
on Sam Setar for having more subscribers than
him.
Sorry.
And.
I just thought it was weird because it's like,
well, I've described it to Sam security as
its guide to you.
So, I mean, like it turns out, I guess you
guys are, like, feuding over it.
So like it to me, it's like two ball fighting
over a comb.
I love that two bald men fighting over a comb.
But every once in a while, you know, I had
I had a funny conversation with with Sam when
this was all going on, when we were trying
to get to a million subscribers on YouTube
and so was he.
And I said, you know, the reason that every
time I talk about it, I say, by the way, guys,
this is a joke, is because there are people
in the audience who think that this is serious.
And I don't remember Sam's response.
I don't know if he was incredulous or what
was or maybe he said, don't worry about that.
It's funnier that some people think it's real.
I still get emails from people saying, David,
I think it's really disrespectful what you're
saying about Sam Ceder.
And, you know, the left shouldn't be inviting.
It's just a joke, guys.
It's just a joke.
We got to a million, Sam got to a million.
All is good.
Independent progressive media is growing and
it's a great thing.
And we're excited about all of it.
And it's all a fantastic thing.
And by the way, we are now our target now
is one point five million YouTube subscribers.
I know that it seems like just yesterday we
were getting to one million.
It was actually three, three months ago.
We are now almost at one point three million
subscribers.
And it would be nuts if within twenty twenty
one we were able to get to one point five
million subscribers.
But that's for a future fake feud.
It's not for right now.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
The Georgia secretary of state has launched
an investigation into Donald Trump's so-called
perfect phone call asking for 11000 votes.
We will talk about that.
A judge has ruled that recreational cannabis
in South Dakota is unconstitutional, as written
in the measure that was recently up for four
vote there.
And we also have found out, I don't know how
many of you saw this, but there was a streaker
in the Super Bowl on Sunday night.
Apparently, that was a planted streaker by
a YouTube.
I'm going to talk about the implications of
this, the importance.
And I actually I want to talk a little bit
about the policy that many networks have of
swinging the camera away, cutting away from
streakers so as not to encourage them by promoting
what they're doing and showing what they're
doing.
I want to talk about whether that's effective
and whether there might be other ways to to
to deal with it.
So all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show.
And, of course, you get instant access to
the bonus show by becoming a member at Join
Pakman Dotcom and live all week, including
today with Donald Trump's second impeachment
trial.
We will be live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
I hope you will join me.
I believe you will.
And we will see what we get from that.
I believe it will be an illuminating experience
and a frustrating one.
I will see you then.